I am in the grass into Columbia Business
School and i'm here at Davos I'm just
facilitating a fascinating lunch in
session come on entrepreneurship just
creating new opportunities within
announcer and we spent it sometimes
touching on some of the things that
should companies up when we don't do
this sort of the existing structure or
example doesn't support of doing the
same some of the incentive system does
many more people having other things or
the ideas get squashed by the existing
corporate bureaucracy but one of the
points that I thought was most
interesting was the company's most
struggle and accepting the level of
people being innovative going to have to
tolerate certain engine failure and the
concert when I was particularly
intrigued by is an idea that I call
intelligent filler which is you create a
contract with you people and that says
it's okay to fail if you meet certain
conditions and the kinds of conditions
on thinking of is the action was
carefully planned so though it fails you
know why and you've launched rendered
and you don't have to repeat that value
again secondly it was a carefully
designed so it was low in risk it was
quick hillcrest so that you build in
mechanisms to share over me with others
oh and so the evil rigorous post-mortem
process to or negate to other people if
something didn't go wrong they can
benefit home and I think getting better
it's failing intelligently is really
going to be important to the
intrapreneurs of tomorrow